là la taille d'une cerise l'effet de
véritable tissu humain et même s'il est
encore incapable de pomper du sein ce
qu'a réalisé à l'aide d'une imprimante
3d pour être un jour sauver des vies ce
tour de force a été réalisée par une
équipe israélienne
ils ont d'abord prélever des cellules de
tissus adipeux d'un patient maison
multipliant laboratoire puis
reprogrammées en cellules souches
capables de se transformer en n'importe
quel matériel humain encore au stade de
la recherche la bio impression progresse
rapidement dans plusieurs secteurs
médicaux comme le développement de
prothèses ou le remplacement de
fragments d'ossements qui sont
reproduits couche par couche avec des
matériaux synthétiques la cause du
risque élevé de rejet lors de certaines
transplantation les organes comme le cas
gagnerait à être reproduits à partir de
véritables des humains et surtout ceux
du patient lui-même
pour l'instant le coeur miniature
parvient se contracter mais sans plus
le chercheur estime que d'ici un an ou
deux on pourra transplantés et faire
fonctionner avec succès un choeur
imprimé en 3d dans un petit cobayes
comme une souris ou un lapin ici normand
grondin radio canada montréal